At the end of the previous video,
we refined our initial question, how popular were the different brands of
candy to a precisely formulated statistical inference problem in which we
want to create a regression estimator for interselection time.
Now before we can do that,
we must identify what features we'd like to use in our model.
As you know, if our goal is prediction, we must choose features which have
some kind of influential force over our response variable.
Which in this case is interselection time.
Our goal now is to identify what those features might be.
What features would you use for the model?
The types of brands?
The number of each type of candy in the bowl?
The time of day?
Or the type of candy?